please welcome the man behind brooklyn
banana bread company sean reynolds hi
sean
hi ross hi thank you for having me i'm
so excited to be here
you know as you can see i bought some of
that brooklyn banana bread for you which
i am not going to lie all i want to do
is ask you a question and hear your
answer as i chew
because i've been waiting to try it
reading your story was so moving
and will you tell us about bringing the
bread to your girlfriend and kind of the
origin story okay so during the height
of covid my girlfriend she's a nurse and
um i was hearing the story she would
call me crying stressed
so i figured what can i do to uplift her
and her colleagues
so i decided to bake my mother's
delicious banana bread
and i went up there and gave them gave
her unit some banana bread then i
started thinking
well she has friends and colleagues who
are
health care professionals and work at
other hospitals why not donate to those
other units as well
and then i took it a step further and
say hey you know what let me
donate to every hospital in new york
city wow
wow
come on sean
so and how's that journey going
delivering to every hospital in new york
it's going great i mean i i've done
almost everyone except for four but i've
done hospitals in connecticut new jersey
delaware maryland um she and i we even
took a trip
we took a trip down to the george floyd
memorial and gave out some deer gave out
some tofu distribution center out there
in minneapolis so i i'm just having a
great time
showing love and appreciation to those
who helped take care of us during this
time oh come on that is the goal right
that's so amazing are you like this like
where does this
kindness this generosity
this energy where does it come from so
i grew up in a christian household where
there were
values and principles instilled in me
some of those values were working hard
being a good financial steward
showing love and giving back
and my mother really embodied that
loving and giving back
her generosity
showed
so that's part of my dna so now i just
work hard at loving and giving back
ah
that is so
great and i love it it's your mom's
spirit in there it's also her recipe
here and i know you spent a lot of money
uh doing this uh like fifteen thousand
dollars own money my own money over
fifteen thousand dollars wow of my own
money you know i um
a lot of people out here hurting
you know and it saddens me
to know that they're hurting
and as long as i have breath in my lungs
and i have the capacity to do it
i will help those individuals that i can
i'm so lucky to hear your story we're
all so lucky to hear your story thank
you
thank you what is next for you
well i'm i'm looking forward to the next
12 000. what would that bring you know
i'm going to continue donating i want to
donate and finish up with the firehouses
and the emt houses and the police
departments and you've got like four
more to go then where does the mission
go like you put this stamp on you're
like okay
i checked all those boxes and and then
where does your journey take you well
sometimes the journey finds me
you know i sit back and i have i have
goals for myself
and for um for donating but sometimes it
finds me you know so for me ultimately i
would love to to establish a foundation
where we can start to make this implant
these type of donations in every city
well if you build it they will come and
i appreciate that life advice to stay
open
to the road that presents itself and i
appreciate that so much um and we just
admire and appreciate everything you're
doing and our friends at um clabbergirl
baking powder i appreciate you too and
they want to chip in 5 000
to your ongoing campaign
and i'm gonna match it so that's ten
thousand dollars wow
because we
appreciate everything you're doing you
are like the living example
and it's the celebration of your mom too
i don't have words
to explain how i feel right now
i just i just thank you thank you i
thank
i thank all of you for allowing me to
share a story of love and compassion
you know and i think that's that's what
we need in in this world you know you do
what you can and then and and and and
make sure you take care of your
neighbors and you know what sometimes
words are cheap your actions says
everything and may we all be more like
you so how about that yes please
thank you thank you guys
thank you thank you for everything that
you do thank you sean reynolds and if
you go to the drewberrymore show.com
you'll find all about the brooklyn
banana bread company and how you can
support and get that yummy banana bread
as well
[Music]